no cost to you.
>> Bill: A MASSIVE TENT CITY
POPPING UP IN TEXAS.
1500 MIGRANTS WHO TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID INTO McALLEN
IN THE PAST WEEK ALONE.
BILL MELUGIN.
>> HOW BAD IT IS GETTING DOWN
HERE, THE CITY OF MCALLEN
DECLARED A LOCAL DISASTER AND
NOT HAPPY WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
LOOK AT THE VIDEO WE SHOT
YESTERDAY FROM THE GROUND AND
DRONE.
AN EMERGENCY TENT COMPOUND THEY
BUILT OVERNIGHT ESSENTIALLY
WHAT IT DOES IT HOUSES ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS RELEASED BY BORDER
PATROL.
THE CITY SAYS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN DUMPING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN DOWNTOWN
MCALLEN AND THEY CAN’T HANDLE
IT ANYMORE.
BUS LOADS BEING DROPPED OFF AT
THE CATHOLIC CHARITY.
THE CITY SAYS THERE IS A RISK
OF MIGRANTS BEING LEFT OUT ON
THE STREETS OF MCALLEN.
THEY HAD TO BUILD THE COMPOUND
AND MIGRANTS SHOWED UP
YESTERDAY.
THE CITY BLASTED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAYING THE CITY
INTENDS TO DEMAND RELIEF FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR THE
ALARMING NUMBER OF MIGRANTS
BEING RELEASED INTO THE CITY OF
MCALLEN.
AS THESE IMMIGRANTS ARE
RELEASED, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT TEST THEM
FOR COVID-19.
WHO DOES TEST THEM?
THIRD PARTY PROVIDER AND WE GOT
SHOCKING STATS FROM THE CITY
HERE FOR YOU.
LOOK AT THIS GRAPHIC.
CITY OF MCALLEN SAYS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS RELEASED
7,000 COVID-POSITIVE MIGRANTS
INTO THEIR CITY JUST SINCE
FEBRUARY.
MORE THAN 1500 OF WHICH WE WERE
IN THE LAST WEEK ALONE.
WE TALKED TO LOCAL RESIDENTS
WHO AREN’T HAPPY TO SEE THE
TENT COMPOUND POP UP IN THE
MIDDLE OF THEIR CITY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> PLANES AND BUSES TO GET ALL
THESE PEOPLE OUT OF HERE AND
THIS IS AN OVERFLOW FROM THE
CENTER.
WE GET THAT, TOO.
BUT AGAIN, THERE COULD HAVE
BEEN A BETTER LOCATION THAN
STICKING IT RIGHT SMACK IN THE
MIDDLE OF MCALLEN.
>> THERE WERE SOME PROTESTORS
AT THE COMPOUND YESTERDAY AND
JUST LEARNED THE CITY HAS
DECIDED TO MOVE IT TO COUNTY
PROPERTY.
IT IS BEING SET UP AT A PARK IN
A DIFFERENT LOCATION.
ONE LAST THING TO POINT OUT.
HORRIBLE CRASH THAT HAPPENED AN
HOUR NORTH OF US IN BROOKS
COUNTY YESTERDAY.
A POSSIBLE SUSPECTED HUMAN SNUG
SMUGGLING INCIDENT.
30 IMMIGRANTS.
THE DRIVER VEERED OFF THE ROAD
AND 10 PEOPLE ARE DEAD, 20
INJURED AND AGAIN, THIS IS
BEING INVESTIGATED AS A
POSSIBLE HUMAN SMUGGLING
INCIDENT.
TRAGIC SITUATION THERE.
WE’LL SEND IT TO YOU.